Once an app is verified to
be from an approved source,
iOS enforces security measures,
designed to prevent it from compromising
other apps, or the rest of the system.
All third party apps are sandboxed,
so that they are restricted from
accessing files stored by other apps,
or from making changes to the device.
This prevents apps from gathering or
modifying information
stored by other apps.
Each app has a unique home directory for
its files, which is randomly
assigned when the app is installed.
If a third-party app, needs to access
information other than its own,
it does so only by using services
explicitly provided by our iOS.
System files and resources are also
excluded from user's apps.
The majority of iOS,
as well as the third party apps,
run as a non-privileged user mobile.
The entire iOS petition
is mounted as read only.
Unnecessary tools,
such as remote locking services,
are not included in the system software.
The iOS APIs, do not allow apps
to escalate their own privileges
to modify the apps or iOS itself.
To summarize,
by sandboxing a third party app,
each app has its unique directory, and
can access its own files, any access
to other files will be restricted.